il est 16h 50 à elancourt kevin du gué
architecte système dans un groupe
aéronautique sort du travail il va
rentrer chez lui mais avant cela il doit
aller chercher sa passagère à quelques
kilomètres de là depuis deux semaines
cet automobiliste fait du covoiturage
avec la hausse des prix du carburant il
a trouvé un moyen de réduire sa facture
j'ai fait mon calcul puisque je fais pas
du covoiturage tous les jours et je
devrais obtenir à peu près une trentaine
d'euros dans le mois sur une semaine
l'automobiliste fait à peu près 2 à 3
trajet en covoiturage ce qui lui permet
d'être également autonome quand ils le
souhaitent ils utilisent l'application
claque site qui met en relation un
conducteur et un passager pour un
parcours domicile travail en plus je
cherchais un moyen de pouvoir faire des
économies de carburant tout en
contribuant un petit peu l'environnement
et il m'a dit ah bah tiens moi j'utilise
une application claque site assez
régulièrement ces pratiques t'as pas
grand-chose à faire ta lutte à
t'inscrire et finalement les gens se
mettent en relation assez facilement
donc j'ai essayé et shinhan quelques
jours après j'ai rencontré sophie
direction bois d'arcy kevin du game est
environ 5 minutes pour récupérer sophie
leclerc technicienne laboratoire en
contrôle qualité il ne fait aucun détour
sur son trajet quotidien salut ça va ça
passer une bonne journée
on compte joint à trouver un emploi donc
on n'avait qu'une seule voiture pour
nous deux donc je prenais la voiture
jusqu'à présent sauf que bâle a vu qu'il
a trouvé un emploi lui a besoin de la
voiture pour aller à son travail et du
coup bah moi j'ai besoin de covoiturer
ou de prendre le bus qui est plus facile
pour moi du coup ce que c'était soit ça
soit racheter une voiture ile-de-france
mobilité est en partenariat avec
l'application claque site sophie de
claire détenant un pass navigo peut
obtenir jusqu'à deux trajets de
covoiturage par jour gratuitement quant
à killing duguay il est rémunéré à
hauteur de 1 euro 50 par trajet et par
passager donc en fait ce gain les
conducteurs au début on peut peut-être
se dire ah bah tiens euros 50 finalement
est ce que ça représente grand chose eh
bien on voit qu'avec la hausse du prix
du carburant il ya de l'intérêt clac
site a constaté une hausse en octobre de
plus de 50 % des inscriptions conducteur
et passagers par rapport à septembre
c'est sûr qu'octobre fait prendre une
conscience une conscience de plus en
plus forte que la voiture finalement
pour une même pour la courte distance eh
bien ça coûte cher début octobre sur
saint quentin en yvelines plus de 40000
trajets sont proposés c'est l'un des
premiers réseaux en france pour
l'application claque site